I think we all know what's gonna happen in the next four seasons of Bridgerton
even though we've been left on this huge cliffhanger
Penelope has had a massive glow up
Lord Debbling has come to town
he is this avid explorer man
pretty sure he's headed off to go to Australia
because they said that it's gonna take a year to where he's gotta go to next
and so yeah he's obsessed
maybe he's a botanist or something like that
I don't know I might have missed it
I wasn't paying that much attention
but anyway he is gonna like go away
travel the world come back every like three or four years or something like that
he's amazing he's great
he's hot he's rich
he's you know successful
he's the catch
she manages to attract the catch of the season
therefore making her eligible in the eyes of the rest of the time society
Mayfair just the way in high school
I had a huge glow up and managed to pull the catch of the year level
and that redeemed my hmm shake your reputation as an opinionated
smart little rebel because I had the approval
um of
you know a guy that was popular that everyone loved
there's no what better way for a woman to achieve validation than through a man
it's patriarchy but I digress
she secures him and everyone's like wow
she must actually be really cool
she must actually be a babe
we haven't even really noticed that is crazy
um and then of course the guy that she actually likes
like the guy next door is like oh oh
ah I see you and then he decides to go for it and then he does and you know
we've all been happy in a carriage
whatever flips the old digit in loves the moment of the mid of consent
thought that was really great props to that
even smut needs consent folks!!
and now we've gotta wait another month to figure out what happens
except we already know what's gonna happen because she's got a secret
Penelope's got a secret Penelope is xoxo Gossip Girl
guy next door said when he finds out who xoxo Gossip Girl is
he's gonna kill xoxo Gossip Girl but he's marrying xoxo Gossip Girl
it's a classic 🦆 marry kill scenario
and then he's gonna get really angry and then she's gonna be like
oh my God
and then it's all gonna come out and then somehow they're gonna end up together
anyway
boring I would like to propose an alternative ending
I would like to propose that the happy ending for her
and I really this not off the cards
but this is what I wanna happen is that she does marry Lord DEBLING LOL I FORGOT HIS NAME
heads off to Australia to colonise us
while he's off colonising the shit out of a country
that very much has native title and sovereignty
which was never seeded
Penelope gets to live her best life funded by colonisation
because you know what dismantle
infiltrate and these women are not in a position to dismantle
they have no power they have to
they are at the whims of the man
so if you're gonna be at the whims of a man
you might as well be at the whims of a man who is very far away
and then she gets left alone for three to four years
probably longer to be honest
he might even get killed while he's over in Australia
and then she'll just inherit his estate
get to fill his library with nice books
get to do her personal projects
get to socialise with her friends
get to write her little xoxo Gossip Girl columns
get to buy pretty dresses and keep glowing up as she has been
get to live her life and I hope that the final scene is her writing
sitting on a windowsill
doing whatever the hell she wants to do with the rest of her life
because I cannot stand if it's another series about how love is the answer
because you know what for some women
being alone in a room a room of one's own is the answer
and I would love to see it
what do you think what do you wanna happen